Task Force X did its job and the world
is safe for now
Suicide Squad may be a critical punching
bag but it still has its rewards for
comic book diehards including a bunch of
references and homage is for the
faithful to enjoy so let's pick up
Harley Quinn's mallet and start smashing
some Suicide Squad Easter eggs watching
The Watchmen remember when Deadshot
looks into the clothing store window and
starts moping out about his daughter
that huge yellow smiley face behind the
mannequins wasn't there by chance in DC
Comics 2016 rebirth event the world of
the Watchmen officially entered the DC
Universe and it may only be a matter of
time before that happens in the movies
as well with this and similar Easter
eggs like The Watchmen graffiti in
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
helping to set up the inevitable frosty
flunky while the Joker mostly employs
nameless goons one of his men sports a
name tag reading mr. frost Brian
Azzarello graphic novel Joker was told
from the perspective of Johnny Frost who
goes from being Joker chauffeur to
becoming his top man the scenes of
Harley shaking her stuff in a nightclub
and mr. frost being the Joker's number
one guy are likely both inspired by
azarello story high-rise tribute this
blinking of missing Easter Egg is pretty
easy to figure out if you know your DC
history the giant building the team
infiltrates to rescue Amanda Waller is
named after comics writer John Ostrander
y los traitor didn't create the original
team that debuted in 1959 he did come up
with a modern Suicide Squad in 1987 what
goes around comes around
when Captain Boomerang convinces
Slipknot his neck bomb is a dud the
scene mirrors what happens in the comics
after boomerang tells Slipknot that
their wrist mounted bombs were fake of
course in the comics the bomb only blew
off his arm instead of his head now you
win some you lose some dancing with the
devil in the pale moonlight some people
might prefer Harley Quinn's classic
black and red costume but at least her
original outfit appears in the movie
when the squad prepares to go to Midway
city
Harley pulls out a familiar looking
outfit but tosses it aside in favor of
something a bit more
for bad guys it's what we do we also got
to see Margot Robbie done the classic
Harley get up in a flashback sequence
which recreates artist Alex Ross's
iconic cover to 1999's Batman Harley
Quinn time away from mr. J after being
let down by the Joker a few times
throughout the movie hardly appears to
have some second thoughts about her
maniacal boyfriend ha her budding
friendship and flirtatious chemistry
with Will Smith's Deadshot
is a callback to what happens in the
comics and the animated feature Batman
assault on Arkham where things
occasionally got hot heavy and downright
weird between these two Batman villains
I got an itch I thought you could help
me scratch cowboy flash back this easter
egg is kind of obvious but it's still
pretty awesome Captain Boomerang
introductory flashback sequence shows a
jewelry store robbery in which his
getaway is stopped by Ezra Miller's
flash it's only right that Captain
Boomerang is thwarted by the Scarlet
speedster since he first appeared as a
flash villain way back in 1960 in an
interview with Collider director David
Ayer revealed that this scene was shot
while Suicide Squad was in
post-production this scene was directed
by Batman vs Superman director Zack
Snyder while he was filming Justice
League thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know if there are any
other Suicide Squad Easter eggs that
should have made the list